[MUSIC PLAYING]
Do you have a lyric?
Right here, but they're not finished yet.
Come on.
[MUSIC CONTINUES]
(RAPPING) Come on, girl.
You know how much I want you.
Like a ghost, I'm going to haunt you.
Meet me at me crib.
Bring your friends.
Maybe we can drive a Mercedes Benz.
We'll hang out poolside, have a drink.
Swimming against the tide, not going to sink.
Come on, girl.
Let's get in trouble.
Shaken not stirred, the James Bond from Dublin.
What's it called?
"Dublin 07," like James Bond but Dublin.
Yeah.
You need a better title.
Let me try something here.
(SINGING) We got something real.
(RAPPING) I'm the joker with the Glasgow smile.
Ready to die for you, I go in style.
Dressed from head to toe in Italian.
In the bed, I'm like a stallion.